[Music]  blake shelton joins gwen stefani for an  epic no doubt duet the power couple hit  the stage together on Sunday night  during Blake's and BS and Friends  after-party show at the House of Blues  in Las Vegas just hours after the pair  attended the Academy of Country Music  Awards when came out for a surprise set  performing hollaback girl before Blake  joined her for the 2002 no doubt hit  [Applause]  the country crooner rocked alongside his  ladylove and proudly sang drink in hand  at the top of his lungs the pair made  the crowd go wild by ending the  performance with this Blake and Gwen had  a busy weekend in Sin City on Friday the  48 year old singer celebrated her  upcoming Las Vegas residency at Planet  Hollywood  Blake of course was right by her side  [Music]  [Applause]